تقرر الاتي اولا اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
جميع انحاء البلاد
ما بعد هذه القرارات ليس كما قبلها يبدا
عام 2022 على وقع قرارات لرئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي حل بموجبها الحكومه
المدنيه واعلن حاله الطوارئ في ارجاء
البلاد
اما الثاني من يناير فيسجل ضمن المحطات
البارزه في المشهد السوداني
منصب رئيس الوزراء يدفع حمدون باستقالته
بعد اقل من شهرين على اعادته للسلطه ضمن
اتفاق سياسي مع قائد الجيش استقاله ادخلت
البلاد التون فراغ سياسي وتشريعي
الانقسامات والتحالفات السياسيه شكلت
العنوان الابرز لمرحله ما بعد الفراغ
الدستوري هنا تتدخل الاليه الثلاثيه للدفع
بحوار سياسي يهدف الى انهاء الازمه
السياسيه وعوده البلاد الى مسار الحكم
المدني
سلام على خطي الازمه تدخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لقاء مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي مع مجموعه مجلس المركزي
والمكون العسكري مهد المشهد لتطور اخر
فالتدخل الامريكي حينها طرح سؤالا جوهريا
عن رؤيه واشنطن وتصورها للاوضاع في
السودان امريكا تريد استقرار سياسهم في
السودان تريد سلام تريد اعاده السودان الى
ما قبل همم عام 83 تريد جيشا يخدم بشكل
مشترك عن المصالح الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه الحيويه
[موسيقى]
في الاسبوع الاول من يوليو اعلن الجيش
انسحابه من العمليه السياسيه لتفتح الساحه
بعدها على مبادرات لانهاء الازمه وتشكيل
حكومه كفاءات مستقله
[تصفيق]
في الخامس من ديسمبر توافق المكون العسكري
وقوه سياسيه على اتفاق يرتكز على دستور
اللجنه التسيريه لنقابه المحامين
السودانيين
لاتفاق الذي ايدته بعض القوى قابلته موجه
انتقادات كونه قفل الباب امام تيارات
وقوته جنسيه ولم يحظى بالنقاش والتداول
الازمه السودانيه ولكن للاسف صار مصدر
للاستقطاب وصراع السياده لذلك ستدخل
البلاد في حاله الدواء ومن الازمه وسيكون
مستقبل بالله طعامنا في العام الجديد
عام 2022 ظل التحداثه متحركه ومتغيره لكن
الثابته فيها التظاهرات الشعبيه الداعيه
لحكم مدني كامل والرفيده لوجود العسكريين
في المشهد السياسي مع مطالبتها بمحاكمه
قتلت المتظاهرين
عام يمضي على السودانيين حصاده فراغ
دستوري وازمه اقتصاديه متصاعده وواقع امني
خلف نحو 900 قتيل نتيجه اعمال العنف
القبلي في البلاد واقع يامل كثيرون الا
ينسحب بتداعته على مجريات العام المقبل
نزار البداوي الجزيره الخرطوم